what happened on Monday was first
there's conversation about the fact that
the cameras were sent to Glendale which
is that was silly right right I was my
fault yeah goofed
yeah big goof that was a tremendously
sloppy error yes yes and then and then
we realized as we were talking about it
that Anthony didn't know the cameras
were shipped to the wrong address which
led us to believe that Anthony had not
listened to the shows because we did
talk about it oh you're shaking your
head what's your objection you know that
that was the whole you know if all I'm
saying is if if I ship the cameras to
the wrong spot this would be done for 45
minutes to an hour about how I'm
incompetent how I'm a PC well I don't
know if anybody was happy [ __ ] yeah
probably yeah how how I'm you know how I
I have I would never pay attention how
am I you know sloppy and everything
that's fair and you know he Oh
goof yeah goof sorry okay let's move on
well it's [ __ ] [ __ ] okay Jim said
he was tremendously sloppy also don't do
you think that things should be taken as
individual things or a person's history
of sloppiness should be brought into
play when I'm just saying like a repeat
offender like almost like if you go to
jail if you're going to court and say
you you're speeding or you're drunk
driving you get your license take it but
if it's my fourth drunk driving offense
you're going to jail and you lose lives
for ten years or in this case 208 you
two yeah yeah but Rob did seven look I
was pissed off we needed those counters
Sharon Osbourne admitted really mad
absolutely how did you get the wrong
address just googled it I googled it and
you know how if you google something now
especially an address it'll come up like
the main address yeah I'm up on there it
was the biggest one right there I was
like well how you didn't follow up I
didn't follow up okay slide yes okay Jim
and I had multiple conversations about
how sloppy Rob was of course and I felt
awful right like Tuesday when you texted
me that I was like oh my god Wednesday
pretty much the whole day I was just in
a funk listening and just waiting for
you guys to say something right
Wednesday night I was like oh maybe
they're just gonna like kind of brochure
and then like Thursday morning I was
like home and rocks at me multiple I'm
sorry text yes none of which I responded
to because I wanted to make them feel
even worse yep it did wait behind how
did you find out we had addressed it
um wait I'm sorry how did you find out
we had addressed it oh I was listening
Oh
did it make you feel better when Juliet
who is helping us out in LA no he also
took a shot it was just let she say she
goes we go we were talking about the e
we moved on from Rob yeah and we were
talking about the app you get read this
on demand anything we moved on from Rob
and we gotta get an account yes
oh that's right and we were talking
about the app and and I was saying that
Howard's video looks really amazing on
the app and then Juliet piped in with oh
so Rob didn't send Howard Stern's camera
you know she was so nice and emails and
everything too but she now yeah you
deserved it absolutely yeah
yeah at least we got that time secure
today from afterbuzz so we'll upload
that on YouTube to write so well we
didn't get the Jim afterbuzz right yeah
yeah yeah you think you think he was
saying the wrong way we should right
yeah yeah that was no I mean like we
have the footage yeah give it to the
people because Jim and I were able to
get her yes from after but after that we
circumvented you yeah yeah we were able
we were like well if if we're gonna be
met with incompetence back home let's
find a crew in LA that I really can can
do something right now that would that
was what Jim was that you're thinking
yeah yeah okay okay so we did we thought
we'd give a quiz sure about what
happened in that light now here's the
thing we wanted the advance any time to
but we [ __ ] with you but we want to
give you time to get to catch up right
listen to 15 hours of audio well I mean
it was 48 hours ago so yeah I took notes
you didn't oh yeah so you did not go
back in and listen to the show okay
other stuff after the show I have to cut
interviews and stuff oh I see I mean to
overwork you okay yeah I get it
I'm sorry sergeant being an [ __ ] man
I can't listen to the show if I'm
cutting interviews for the show I think
Rob is laughes getting what's getting to
you you have talking to Mike what's
wrong but everything's me why just
I'm just very [ __ ] pissed off at this
whole situation what situation that I
you you guys make it seem like I was
[ __ ] how my feet up in the office and
just wasn't paying attention to show I
was doing a thousand things for the show
I was making sure that there were forty
five to fifty new interviews that week
to put up on demand and okay so that's
one see me I'm waiting
no you just did a thousand so you think
it takes ten minutes to do 45 minute 45
interviews how long does it take I have
to pull the shows from delet while I
pull the shows from the light I cut
other shows right if none of them girls
from delight because none of them are on
the CDs from from one before I was human
I'm pretty sure even if you just worked
a standard workday right how long is a
standard workday 8 hours yeah with
launch seven hours 7 hour okay seven how
many days work days in a week okay so
even if you did the minimum 35 hours
right yeah okay okay
I [ __ ] up I don't know what you I
really honestly don't know what you want
from me I mean I really know you're
saying you're upset cuz you it doesn't
take ten minutes to do all these
interviews what I'm saying was I wasn't
[ __ ] just sitting back there and not
doing anything I was doing stuff I had
my headphones on I was cutting stuff
simultaneously I couldn't hear every
single thing that happened on the show
you wouldn't hear it do you think it's
crazy that the show feels like the
producer should know what's happening on
the show it's like a it's not a case
it's not a case of hey you should listen
and enjoy like as a fan no one is saying
that the point is more like because
you're working on the show and part of
what you do is grab audio for stuff or
you might hear something and go you know
what I remember when they referenced
this I can use literally just for
archiving purposes in your brain so
you've heard it and you kind of know who
we've had and what the the tone of it
was or if there's anything you can use
that's where it's coming for it's not
coming from hey listen to what we're
saying it's terrific it's not it's not
about that of course not
yeah it's just a matter of like if we
say something on the air if something
happens on the air we know we've got a
team that's gonna be like okay that's
like stuff is gonna get taking picture
this picture you're working with Rick
Rubin or somebody else you're Co
producing a record or a CD and you and
there's a you're out one day because
you're sick and they're in there doing
sessions they're doing the guitar lead
and a few other things and they're like
what did you think of this stuff that
they did yesterday
I didn't hear it people wouldn't be like
you've missed a great lead they'd be
like well we're putting a record
together you should have heard it just
so you kind of know are aware and you
could say yes that meant something or B
that meant nothing that makes sense
that's that's where it's coming for and
these aren't best of shows I got I'm not
saying like did you listen to the best
stuff over the weekend like that would
be crazy yeah I don't listen to best of
right neither do I don't have anything
right I don't believe that exists no but
you know their live shows really it's
the same thing as what goes on here the
same way I would hold you or we would
hold you responsible for anything we do
on the air here just because we're doing
it from a different studio doesn't mean
that the staff would be less responsible
for it right yes yes you're right I
don't I don't know you're right you're
right I [ __ ] up I should have listened
to the show I should've went back and
listened to the show
I apologize it won't happen again I
don't believe you Roger
you heard the show yeah I listened on
the app it was great you liked it
I mean the app is awesome that you have
to update is great is it great kitchen
about that I've heard a lot of good
things no no not before not in ago it's
tough to find like the actual page like
a Jim and Sam page but there's always
like wise enough to find out they're
working on that yeah so it's it's kind
of just like that popped on and there's
stuff up front all the time always up
front always like hey here's the last
interview here's what you missed and all
that's intuitive it knows what you
listen yes is it like your home page
yeah I have about know if it's on my
phone if I took it off I have to see if
I still have it yeah it was crashing it
was a problem I couldn't leave the old
MBA idea was [ __ ] up oh well be a band
when they say they released the beta a
while ago and everyone got an email
about it and it's like hey boys yes yeah
yeah yeah and it's like send you know
information back and forth like a do you
like this do you not oh wow this number
one show right up top number one oh wow
Jesus
are you [ __ ] let me say me what are
they doing the number one show on the
food court like I said it's Intuit knows
what you listen to it knows that I
listen to a lot of faction talk so it's
putting that up there because I haven't
listened to it so it's like maybe you
want this just amazing I kind of love it
so do I roll looks great in that photo
foodcourt my god but then you scroll
down and there's all that Jim and Sam
stuff right there so if you scroll a
little bit well yeah because you got to
go to your jump back in because I'm
listening see I've been listening to
these things oh cool what do you want to
how should we do this we have them each
write down the answer yep okay hmm now
I'm gonna tell you something that I
heard Don winkling thinks the choice
should be involved in this game too but
you're right but here's the only reason
it's happening cuz immediately when I
walked in the studio I don't really
wanna play with Troy because I mean when
I walked in the studio Troy was like hey
this was funny that was funny you know
what I mean so it's like oh you were
listening to the show you know I didn't
yeah I enjoyed the LA shows I don't know
if I heard every single second of every
show but I definitely enjoyed the shows
you have a pen ROM yes you knew
something half of the cameras absolutely
okay Anthony you have a pen over there
can somebody grab Anthony a pen yeah
just so he's got it so he can go okay
all right that's a good question
no cheating no looking at papers over
there maybe make em I like this mic
better so it's a cycle there gets it
I'll flip it over babe yeah keep it on
just cover with your hand keep it on
yeah you want to you want to start
asking these questions Jim okay number
one question of our la trip why do we
have any music we can play we should
play some happy radio musical game show
music playing jeopardy perfect and you
what do you have a buzzer and a ding I
can get one yeah yeah let's get some
Sanders okay
so what's the question first question
Who am I um
it's Alex Trebek coming to he's trying
to figure out his role that was
medicated Jim okay it's sorry doing good
yeah
yeah it's just stinks
once the timing of everything on the
corner of Jim feeling even gym at 5:00
why was jim Florentine in Los Angeles
why was jim Florentine in North Los
Angeles now people may or may not
remember I remember last Monday jim
Florentine was on the show from Los
Angeles okay okay the next question yes
you can ask the next question this is
good
what audio did Jim and Sam listen to
while xpac was in studio I have to think
while xpac was in studio they're in Los
Angeles why'd you guys are gonna go one
by one
Oh we'll just keep replaying it way way
away
what was the audio I have to think of it
that's okay what was the audio I
remember it how'd you do it Sam
Robb feeling confident we're gonna need
a an answer young Anthony just write
something you have to put it answer
right just you know all right
I guess is still it's still good Jim
would you like to move to cry would this
is a great one okay question number
three okay what did Bobby Lee do after
his car was towed one of the best
stories yeah from the Los Angeles show
yes
Troy's already smiling you remember this
one finally Troy yeah you like that one
one of the great stories from Bobby Lee
in Los Angeles I believe that was
Wednesday morning show Wednesday morning
Bobby Lee was on ok we move on to
question number 4 Tom Segura revealed
that Sam
had sex with whom Tom Segura do you
remember that on Thursday morning show
made the declaration that I the last
professional broadcaster Sam Roberts had
sex with whom to know but I can't
remember who is there
you don't remember no do you remember
I'm saying it no I'm we're talking I'm
picturing the view of Tom's sneakers and
liking his sneakers right picturing
Tom's sitting there no I got a lot of
comments on this on Twitter I know a lot
of people you want to go to question
number Jim om this I remember part of
who's the Jensen carp dating Jensen carp
Tuesday morning show who is Jensen carp
dating actually you know and this might
be helpful he's engaged now I believe
he's engaged to this person ddddd Hadid
would that be annoying I think it's
actually great it adds yeah thanks yeah
how are you guys feeling by the way
we're about halfway through how you guys
pretty good Anthony Carboni feeling no
comment nope okay maybe cut maybe
feeling better than anybody expects you
possibly bro Rob off his game oh this is
good number six oh now what Quentin
Tarantino movie did Jim recently watch
for the first time Rob very quick to
write this one I can actually write down
but very very good and actually Anthony
very quick to write that one down too
this was a shocking bit of information
okay what type of woman did what type of
women did Moshe like before marrying
Natasha okay now this is a bit of a
giveaway question because we mentioned
it here in New York once we got back but
still points his points and the final
question this is a really good one
other than Nelson Mandela name two
examples of the Mandela effect that Jim
and Sam discussed with Bobby Lee when
Bobby Lee was in we discussed the
Mandela effect we played audio
if you remember what were two examples
of the many of the Mandela effect they
look like Bobby Lee
it looks like pens down for Anthony I
was breaking a lot of wind that day you
were you're breaking a lot mainly just
for the Bobby Lee's a lot of wind and
looks like we're gonna go pens down for
Rob okay so eight questions good job by
oho Travis you do this I did you well
done it yes so Travis has has our answer
key there's a good quiz yeah you like
that I like that quiz okay you like that
quiz Anthony did you like that quiz it
was great okay Anthony is also like that
quiz he sounds confident he sounds sure
of himself
yes he does this could go well
especially because everybody had two
days notice that this quiz was missing
it's not exactly it's not exactly a pop
quiz this is like on Monday if your
science teacher says like we're gonna
have a test on right and then you get
there on Friday and you're like what the
[ __ ] yeah I got all these other classes
what do you want me to do is there
anything worse than your science test
and then you look at it you go like I
literally I know so nothing that I can't
even guess yeah yeah I have I can't even
guess when you look at the question and
you're like this question makes no sense
what is the process of photosynthesis
what a cover huh like I can't even
[ __ ] pretend I have an idea of what
this might be
no never it's blank it doesn't make any
sense zero would you have that when
you're doing science test it would
literally be if I had gotten a question
in Chinese it was in the same response I
don't think I've ever heard these words
before these words I've never been put
together in a row in my mind I don't
know miss I don't think you taught us
this because this is totally confused
yes this is not a real you could be
making this up with no facts behind it
right now right then didn't make any
difference
okay well we do we want to have Travis
give the answers and then we'll reveal
what's on the papers since his yes yeah
that makes sense too why was jim
Florentine in Los Angeles oh so I'm
gonna answer oh wait yeah yeah you're
right Travis is right okay
Anthony why was jim Florentine in Los
Angeles to perform at the stand and
Oh or promote his book ah so we're at
negative 2 what else and in LA the
comedy open up the Comedy Store I'm
sorry the store ok negative right
ok so it wasn't the stand or his book
Rob do you have an answer
Mitsy Shores remembrance there it is
Congrats Rob thank you ok that's one for
Rob that's ok
was it at the store it wasn't the comedy
store yes you didn't perform know you
were thinking even show he was into a
show it was it was a I thought you like
to perform the show from a t-shirt but
the yeah I would have given you points
if you'd said performance over Missy
sure no you wouldn't if you'd said Mitzi
sure I absolutely give you today
anything with Mitzi in it I was no even
you were wrong if you had just that
would been ok yeah that would have been
fine question number two what audio did
Jim and Sam listen to while Xbox was in
studio Anthony no let him go for I don't
I don't have anything I'm something what
is there at some post oh you just wrote
the word something ok was it the stalker
20,000 oh my god yes I didn't get that I
got that you know what I would have got
that wrong too that is that is correct
you too by the way needs to be finished
yeah it was good is that more jobs yeah
[Laughter]
do I do question those are you what what
did Bobby Lee do after his car was towed
I already took a [ __ ] it's a good answer
yeah sure it's very and technically in
some ways probably right
yeah that's not we got out of it I
bought another car that's right that's
another Volkswagen I believe yeah -
twenty thousand dollars brown paper bag
there's nothing better than [ __ ]
Bobby Lee going back to the bank you
guys I thought we need a tow to car you
just lost it and him just being like I
was stand-up I don't know what to do and
no insurance yeah no no he bought it he
bought the car in cash and then the car
probably got towed we don't know because
he never checked up on it it just wasn't
where he was just gone so he went
to the bank on another 20 grand and went
back to the dealership and got another
another car they towed it no I don't
know how am I supposed to know these
things I don't know there's nobody
better than Bob Vila he's the greatest
he's the greatest Oh
question number four yep oh this yeah
who just broke wind I was looking down
at the paper
[Laughter]
I'm segura revealed that Sam had sex
with whom that's a great question
Anthony I said Pam Anderson's Mary Jean
after your live nightly show that's
right Mary I didn't even catch that he
did Tom said that he didn't he didn't
know what assumed it you'd say it he
said it was a fat yeah yeah yeah I broke
it from that the wait time question it
came out of nowhere
yeah and Tom just said you're in fact
whatever music he's like are you still
[ __ ] then again yeah well I talk to
Reggie recently and she's and was I was
surprised as she said that I said I wish
Sam would [ __ ] me again
oh my god it was good to know the room
had my back when I said Tom Jim actually
spends personal time with Mary Jean and
Jim said if I had [ __ ] her I would
have told you and Tom said yeah he would
have told me I said god I would have
thanks guys it wouldn't be a secret who
care
no you're right you're right no I
unfortunately unfortunately Tom you're
mad no Tommy's not telling you you're
married and you're unfaithful it's fine
but I wouldn't happen happen cares yeah
what do you do exactly
I don't know what that means and these
things are more open in this elyda tea
in our marriage oh yeah no I
unfortunately and sexual okay well now
that now that we've got all the facts
yeah yeah polyamorous okay I'm glad we
revisited that oh yeah oh this is my
question number five yeah who
Jennsen carp 218 I think Anthony knows
this one because he nodded but I don't
know where he learned this tanga there
is I listened in to that part of the
show of that show okay Anthony is on the
board I would have remembered that
actress from the was it the one day
years or the I would have got that one
wrong I couldn't I didn't know she was
right right but you know with an actress
yeah I wrote Topanga from Boy Meets
World as well okay Wow yeah I was robbed
jealous do those growing up oh my god
yeah you know I know
tell us why me he's not gay it's right
no I know but I'm saying like when I was
growing up there's my freshies Joseph
yeah you were saying whether Jensen was
with Topanga or not he wasn't gonna date
Rob number six what Quentin Tarantino
movie did Jim recently watch for the
first time now Anthony looks very
confident in this one to Jackie Brown
Jackie Brown is right robbed I wrote
Jackie be dismal you do make sure that
bells all around six or six and cut it
to white say oh gosh thanks truth oh
yeah you don't like that Robby's being
extra obnoxious ass kiss someone wants
an apple he's just always just you
always want half office always open up
so I say that wall weird stuff setting
here sometimes what James back to being
medicated oh you're talking about you
want apples all the time I don't know
what's going on it's aunt honestly it's
just down to me and Anthony at this
point I hope I can count on you button
no you can't okay alright well there's
that leaving the trenches with grenades
okay what type of women did oh I
remember
he's on medication again give me five
yeah he's strictly on a five not a one
night at 10:00 he's not a five what type
of women did motion like before marrying
Natasha okay now you remember anything
you're confident this one - I remember a
little bit of a free me because we
mention it but that's I'm not taking
that away from if it's in the quiz it's
fair game right it's like remember that
um
if it doesn't fit you must have quit
like a rhyme like that dynamite drop
engineer I get that it's from the UM Oh
Jay Simpson trial just not a hundred
percent how it correlates to what we're
talking there's just rhyming yeah you
can get that we've been shitty annoying
to our oh my god I would yeah yeah
really annoying yeah so what type
Anthony yep fat woman there he is
I wrote fat chicks okay that works okay
that's a point for each even he's coming
back strong in the second half of this
well say yes I guess yeah this is the
last question right um other than Nelson
Mandela name two examples of the Mandela
effect that Jim and Sam discussed with
Bobby Lee six possible answers six
possible answers Wow and I'll have you
go over the six sure at the end Anthony
was I got nothing zero of this zero not
even in the buzzer six times yeah not on
you know one strategy would have just
been to come up with examples of them
and hope right but you went with if I
say the meant things for the Mandela and
just I don't know okay okay okay that's
it that's a no point I don't know if I
can get two of these either my memory
stinks I really don't know if I can get
two of these I remember us discussing it
well there was one you don't like the
enthusiasm he puts in really laying it
on thick to the show to anything all
those videos that go on YouTube just
don't go anywhere I just don't do them
right we are when I get home yeah I get
paid part-time you just sit here and
your father not the most yesterday was
when I was doing the cleaning up the
studio everything he [ __ ] sat down
and crossed his legs I could [ __ ] him to
me be a part of the group um and you had
to do all the way all the world does it
every day that's I pick I clean up the
cameras he cleans up the studio he sets
up the studio help
I mean it just me it's just whenever you
ask Rob dude how about when you almost
forgot the the iPad for chip and I had
to make sure to tell you where it was
trip would have been because it's locked
in your desk yeah I forgot normally if
you were a good producer that you say
you were you would have said before oh
hey make sure you leave the iPod I'll be
up head up because I got to bring it for
chip Hey and and and he texted me at
6:45 [ __ ] dude 6:45 because we film at
6:30 whenever it was like five hours
beforehand yeah you're right I did yeah
and guess what happened I got it
so cuz know why I should have [ __ ]
just never answered you sure like a lot
of people told me not to they did who
told you not to answer me that day nico
dan where's Nico now exact his
internships over it is intentionally
trying to find a job he was good
so life was like a box of chocolates was
one of them that's true are you oh
that's right et home phone there's two
there's two and the third one if you
want it was extra credit magic mirror on
the wall that's okay they're right I
don't remember the other three I don't
either I didn't remember them - you said
I'm just going oh yes that's correct
I forgot about et home phone what were
the other three oops
Oh T the monopoly guy right monocle yep
right does he or doesn't it doesn't
doesn't people consider that mr. peanut
it's RAM said that that's right listen
to rob and Luke I'm your father
oh you said I'm your right that was only
briefly mentioned but meant right but
still counts he didn't say Luke I like
for that last questions no I am your
father yes Anthony is given the the
photosynthesis science question face
like he's like I don't know what the
[ __ ] you guys are talking about right
this is totally like you guys are on
some other [ __ ] right now Rob got 110
percent he did way to go Rob coming
together you ready we get four right
three three three three out of eight is
that path 40 no no no no that's PI 40
it's less than a 40 and 2 wrong is it
less than 40 I mean you think of it yeah
I didn't I didn't force you twice what
now what is 3 out of 40 what is that 3
of 8 I'm sorry 44 out of 8 would have
been 50%
so what is three out of eight thirty
five okay thirty-five is yeah that's on
the lower end 3.3 yeah that's a complete
fu yeah yeah that's our 37.5 yeah
alright we should we should break
because our Kevin Brennan is coming
anything the moment is here okay Bobby
alright we'll grab him in a second and
uh that's great well urinate thank you
boys for us waiting in the quiz
anytime you didn't want to come back and
listen to the shows how to cut up
interviews yesterday all right that
takes a while because dude it takes five
minutes to cut up in an interview you
literally start from how to get in so we
don't have time to let when you pull
from the lie how long does it take I
don't know why because you don't know
how to [ __ ] do it
don't you in a video Anthony you didn't
know how to do it either
Travis you're not helping well Travis
Paul came to me for Rob's action figure
because either Travis or you he wants
the kids like Tony comes in with a shot
because he sent six links every night in
his emails exit six link Tony is not a
kind nickname no because I sent seven to
eight emails of video when I used to
seven to eight emails him he's like oh
he did manly let me see how many sell si
I say he said it was funny that Rob came
in with all that energy and everybody
was like what's talking about seven
links and then the other one where Sam
actually actually emailed and said this
was a great video of the parking lot
fight yeah but then he's like your job
for you
he still sent another email being like
hey this is the videos know we like yeah
you're right oh I sent that video
afterwards you sent one video of the
video that I thought would be funny for
the show yes that he enjoy understand
that you don't understand a [ __ ]
figure and you're right
you're 100% right he's like a little
baby Rob yeah I don't understand a thing
I'm the baby no no Robin
huh yeah you and you [ __ ] even said
he's a baby and they're in the office
well however when I came to play pub G
I'm not playing that game anymore
funny here's a joke Robbie you still
didn't play right cuz it was a joke
Anthony Anthony joke why do you get mad
why do you get sodas you're a piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] full-time I hate you piece
of [ __ ] yeah you do I do not hate it if
you talk ship W Travis you talk [ __ ] to
me this and other studio yup I know you
do is [ __ ] mind-blowing to me I don't
hate anybody I don't think I don't like
your work ethic Trev I think you're lazy
oh I think the fact that you couldn't go
back on Monday and or yesterday to be
like hey maybe I should breathe brush up
on this stuff
dude you don't even have a subscription
to serious you work here alright so I
emailed Donna can [ __ ] let me get the
subscription you piece of [ __ ] that's
gross keep calling name-calling that's
big you know piece of [ __ ] he's not
funny bring the [ __ ] mic stand here
I'll even get the planks did if you if
you little ride water mics Tamara Robb
is it's the same [ __ ] comedic effect
brilliance the same comedic effect
that's good dude he didn't know you dude
yeah that's funny I like that note it
actually is funny it is funny that's
very laughing and I said he's laughing
everybody's laughing it's a [ __ ]
funny would you call me the one time
Pinocchio that was a good [ __ ] line
Rob dude watch out for 30 micron oh
right because I was the one just sitting
in here before being who you hey are you
worrying about to say what do I say yeah
yeah why walk out of the room no I'm
gonna sit down in case he has to ask me
[ __ ] am I wrong it was it was sitting
here for so long that was so
uncomfortable I mean your get out there
next time you [ __ ] part-timer
go get the food walk out of the studio
that's a good move buddy okay I don't
like his work ethic that's the only
thing I don't like I will say -
Anthony's credit in terms of him sitting
in there there was there was some
entrapment I did encouraging him
sometimes I do encourage him to sit down
knowing he'll sit down for total fool
yeah there isn't there there are
elements of entrapment there that I will
take responsibility but it was funny go
get the coffee he walks on the food it's
the same thing it's the same exact
things really is yeah yeah Jesus